do you remember when you believed in
Santa Claus and how magical that was
tooth fairy
Easter Bunny mermaids are kind of the
same way
Linden Wilbert is a self-described
entrepreneur made for more than a decade
she's been slipping into a self-made
silicone tail to put on what she calls
performances for celebrities kids and
companies I could work non-stop between
all of the different things that I do
within my career music videos films
television you name it potential is
great force and dollars there was no
business model for doing this I really
had to think through all of these
different facets of what it would mean
to create the image and visual and feel
of a mythical creature mermaid Linden is
actually a super athlete she can hold
her breath for five minutes and dive
down 115 feet with one breath of air but
to become a mermaid she needed a tail it
took seven months and more than $20,000
I remember watching how the fluke moved
through the water and it was working and
I was swimming I was a mermaid I was
really a mermaid the day in the life of
a mermaid is pretty unpredictable
there's so much involved in keeping
myself and my business afloat
time to get the baby in the car lugging
her 46 pound to in and out of her home
which she calls her grotto is the usual
start of a day's work for extra sand
dollars Linden is partnering with Body
Glove international an la-based
sportswear company we just started
talking and you know I found out she was
a professional mermaid talked about well
why don't we see if we can work up a
line of mermaid products
over the course of a couple of years we
created a monofin that looks just like
my tail and now I have developed a
really wonderful new product that
actually creates the entire looks of a
full mermaid tail for these children and
we have a mermaid or Merman at work the
lycra mermaid tails are being printed
and sewn in a factory in downtown LA
look how pretty it looks there are my
little babies Linden says the tails
which are meant to be paired with her
kids monofins
will be available for purchase and time
for the lucrative holiday season but
before they can ship they need to be
tested I love living in LA because there
are a lot of swimming pools so it's kind
of a mermaids dream come true I take
very seriously preserving the magic so
children never see me out of my tail
rest from Body Glove has enlisted the
help of his grandchildren their friends
and a neighbor's pool these beautiful
little mermaids are trying on our tails
and our mono fins I think it's going
mirifique Lee
Linden's day doesn't end when the kids
leave back home in her grotto
she patches are pure silicone appendage
this is a silicone based epoxy in
swimming pools it's really tough on the
tails I'm carrying kids around and
sometimes that gets a little trying on
on my baby the business of being a
mermaid is know is easy on the tail or
the body but Lyndon says it's amazing I
play with a mermaid a real I think I
received more than anyone can ever dream
just from sharing magic with children